American B1 bombers flying from Texas to
the Middle East on Thursday part of the
Bon administration's plan to retaliate
for an iran-backed group's drone strike
that killed three US soldiers in Jordan
I don't think
the uh the adversaries are of a
oneandone
mindset uh and so uh they have a lot of
cability I have a lot
more the White House says the b1s and
other war planes bombed at least 85
Targets in Iraq and Syria targets
controlled by the Islamic revolutionary
guard cores KS force and its Affiliates
on Sunday a mandatory notice from
President Joe Biden to Congress about
the event the strikes have been taken to
deter the irgc and Affiliated militia
groups from conducting or supporting
further attacks on United States
personnel and facilities and have been
conducted in a manner designed to limit
the risk of escalation and avoid
civilian
casualties the US also launched air
strikes on hoty Targets in Yemen on
Saturday and on Sunday this in response
to weeks of hoty attacks on commercial
shipping and US Navy warships in the Red
Sea Congressional Republicans accused
Bon of cowardice by targeting Iran's
proxies and not the country itself we
should not be appeasing Iran that's what
the Biden Administration has been doing
for the last 3 years we are projecting
weakness on the world stage Biden's
National Security adviser says that's
not true I would just say from the
perspective of Tyran if they chose to
respond directly to the United States
they would be met with a Swift and
forceful response from us meanwhile a
new round of diplomacy Secretary of
State Anthony blankin is heading to
Israel the occupied West Bank gutar
Egypt and Saudi Arabia for more talks on
ending the war in
Gaza and cooling Regional tensions
Roselyn Jordan aljazera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer